all right kenny and martina
so i've done you i've interviewed you
guys separately but never together
so how did you guys meet when did you
meet
how much anyone was with you that about
[ __ ] probably back in in the late 80s
yeah that's when i no yeah i met martina
but when you got with me back in
uh
90
89 no 89 89 90 yeah yeah
that's when i remember when i was in
hawaii
yeah you had me yeah
but before that yeah yeah before the end
also but that was 89 when i got kicked
off the island i got martina i was in
san francisco i just got back from the
east coast
and uh
i was on the i was on the track
show up his attack
and and i see martina porter i said god
damn [ __ ] you fine you know what i'm
saying i got the car was sweating that
[ __ ] she went and took care of business
after that she jumped in the car and we
rolled off like a thief in the night
and i've been with him ever since
ever since yeah but you know me and
kenny hasn't been together for years but
we have a mutual respect for each other
you know i always i'm always going to
love kenny
you know but um but back then i was just
in love love
love was just down for kenny reds
pimping
and just cross country with it you know
just having fun
when ism was just great you know when it
was rules to this game you know
um
see martinez
a gemini so it was like was dealing with
with two martinez you know what i'm
saying but she went to work handled a
business at any time i mean you know
everybody relationship for the game it
don't be just one-on-one it's ups and
downs
people tell
people tell
the good part but you never tell the bad
parts you see what i'm saying so i mean
our [ __ ] was just like everybody else i
should just laugh along with a bunch of
other people's and everything you know
but you know but i'm just glad at the
end of the day we know we still cool and
everything she do without do mine she
stay in touch i stay in touch you know
other females that i have they stay in
touch i stay in touch and we keep it
moving you know what i'm saying we
living you know there's there's a
romantic element to these relationships
right yeah it's not all it's not purely
business sometimes it's not
i wouldn't be in love i wouldn't just
about somebody breaking on me you know
but um kenny is a romantic person people
don't know that but you have to give
them some money first you don't get all
that goodness from kenny just meeting
him and you know interviewing with him
and being around him you have to give
kenny some money and you're going to see
the softer side of sears yeah
well
while i always knew that you know in the
game you know we all had our ups and
downs and bumps and going over the bumps
and the humps and all that kind of stuff
trying to you know trying to get you you
get your pimping straight and everything
you know i'm saying that's why so many
females that i have they still stay in
contact because i just didn't do them
right dirty like when the [ __ ] left me
you know saying here [ __ ] take this
[ __ ] with you too i'm not no storage i'm
not keeping it martina left me fo that
[ __ ] i got that [ __ ] apartment across
the street from the beach in alameda
that [ __ ] left
and everything i'll get a [ __ ]
furniture away i said i'm not i'm not no
storage company [ __ ] i'm a pimp you
know what i'm saying said should i gave
that [ __ ] away [ __ ] and god yeah and got
rid of [ __ ] [ __ ] she come back but you
got to start all over it ain't on me
right you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah but i mean you know [ __ ] the
time you know and you know the times
have changed oh martina a whole lot man
a whole lot man the game is nothing like
it used to be man you know i'm saying
and that's pros and cons because it's a
good thing too like these girls they
have all these different avenues of
getting money
different ways you know and me i had to
hit the street i was a street stomper so
it wasn't easy like these girls could be
bartenders they get money like hoes they
get tipped and uh bottle service you see
them girls out there naked today at the
pool you know what i'm saying they were
getting money like strippers oh my god
strippers are making money galore like
they don't even got to have sex they
they shaking it they getting getting it
i'm proud of them i'm glad like i said i
handed this game to these girls on a
platter and uh they get into it but on
the other side the game is messed up as
far as
you know people using the word pimp so
loosely and using the word whole so
loosely because the word the word pimp
is like wearing a [ __ ] pair of jeans
now everything is pimped this oh they
look pimpy pimp this pimped it the word
pimp used to have respect you know what
i'm saying now you know they they people
that took it out of the contents you
know once
the pimple don't have no respect no more
you know pimps used to dress up like
entertainers and the whole nine yards
and everything but now you just you
don't know what a pimple like back in
the days you used to know what a pimp
looked like now that you don't know what
a pimp looked like you know some of the
most hated members of society man for
real for real you know it was a dirty
word to society
yeah but they don't know that we're
people too we're people we
it's a secret society you know martina
you'd probably be a great person to
answer this question like
not all pimps are just evil guys that
are gonna you know they're not all
gorilla pimps that are gonna get a girl
high on something and get her addicted
and
no they have ceo pimps they got finesse
pimps they got gorilla pimps
mexican pens why would a why would a
young lady
hook up with somebody like kenny and
give him all the money because i'm a bad
[ __ ] because he is ceo
pimp with a little bit of gorilla with
it you know what i mean but not as much
now kenny has calmed down a lot but one
thing about
no hold on he needs some good minutes
but no but hold on hold on i used to i
used to be detrimental on the [ __ ] i
put my foot in the [ __ ] ass i wouldn't
give a [ __ ] whatever was going down or
whatever i was kicking a [ __ ] in the
ass when you disrespect me a dog you
know disrespect my opinion i was putting
my foot down on the [ __ ] ass but
nowadays and everything just before aj i
mean oj [ __ ] terry tango right now but
not his danny before i put my hands on
on the female i'd rather father go ahead
and get the [ __ ] on you don't say don't
waste my time i ain't gonna waste yours
you see what i'm saying but i didn't get
beat up like that kenny i could name him
on money and i'm no no no no no no no
but i'm not i'm not just talking about
you because you wasn't the only [ __ ]
that i had right i'm saying i had four
or five other [ __ ] when i had martina
you see what's that martinez just was
outlasted the other females that i have
had and all that kind of stuff and
everything but i mean but as a family
and all that kind of stuff you know i
mean when i did you know i had to you
know put the gorilla lagoon hand down
whatever they want to call it and every
time you know [ __ ] know i
wasn't playing you know what i'm saying
but at the same time i mean everything
worked out you know [ __ ] never call the
police on me by putting my hands on the
[ __ ] and all that kind of [ __ ] because
the [ __ ] know that she was wrong
nowadays these [ __ ] is okay for a lot
of these [ __ ] got their phone on
9-1-1 just hit the button you don't say
yeah
this [ __ ] put his hands on me
[ __ ] going to jail or whatever
or the police they don't take it out the
content that's just like that's just
like if if a pimp would have been in the
oscar ward went up there and slapped the
[ __ ] out of chris rockefeller we would
have been in jail look at this but [ __ ]
you know what i said the laws is made up
for who they want to make them up for
just like that pimp slap that catholic
church i mean that that uh priest
yeah but you know i'm not a bitter [ __ ]
i'm a happy hooker and that's what you
want i'm not bitter i love this ism you
know and it was one time you know
i've got tired of it i got tired of you
know pimp getting pimped on and out you
don't have my own escort service but
that don't make me hate the pimping
because guess what the first man i ever
looked up to was my two pimp brothers
that were pimps so i love him i love
this ism this ism is in me not on me you
know what i'm saying that's real life
you know i was exposed to it the time
you spent with kenny did what how did it
change your life
um he changed my life he showed me how
to manage things and he gave me a lot of
intelligence
on um
this was she was my [ __ ] mark you know
what i'm saying and you know mark i
never want to know robots silly ass
[ __ ] any [ __ ] way you know i
don't like them kind of [ __ ] i
mean one time i had two two [ __ ] i
had sent to arizona and my partner was
like damn i can't wait if you went to
arizona and walked across on the other
side of the street which trimmed up them
[ __ ] they wouldn't even know that uh
that who you was because you didn't have
them holds on automatic and everything
you know what i'm saying but and i had
one [ __ ] that gave me five hundred
dollars a day you know you know i said
we call it a 500 you know what i'm
saying but well i mean i mean but she
was cool
and everything but you know mark i
always always taught a female of mine
you know to want something you know
don't nobody want to be in the game and
talk about what they used to do and what
they used to have and they don't have
[ __ ] out the game that's just like
somebody working you don't you don't
want to work and at the end of the day
you ain't got [ __ ] but a [ __ ] picture
check you see what i'm saying and i said
that's all and i tell people right now
you know what i'm saying all working no
play that's that's not it you know what
i'm saying
it don't go like that like when i used
to have wife and laws i used to put it
into fifth gear that's when i really
extra work harder because i want to show
them an example i tell i talked to one
of your ex-wife a lot earlier today she
was uh she said hey what i'm saying i
said she said i'm sending you a few
dollars for your birthday i say i
appreciate that you know what i'm saying
i said that's your support the money
that you sending me from you was short
when he was coming in my house and then
man i was on the phone laughing you know
what i'm saying but i always feel like
you know it's always cool you know to
have you know females that you have had
you're able to talk to them and not be
salty you know what i'm saying so one
thing you don't want you don't want no
angry salty [ __ ] at the end of the day
you see what i'm saying [ __ ] calling
you trying to extort you or what if you
don't give me such-and-such if you don't
give me uh twenty thousand dollars i'm
gonna call the police [ __ ] you ain't
gave me number two thousand now you
wanna give me a case and all that kind
of see this is the kind of things that
they do and it's not fair because the
people they you know the police they go
for that [ __ ] and then you know make it
harder on the man you see them that's
just like i got some friends want to
come sit and talk to me about what they
used to do oh that's it's cool and fine
and dandy and everything but guess what
though what's going on now you know what
i'm saying because the average [ __ ]
well i mean the average pimp
they only got like 20 25 years and
that's it and it's over
you see what i'm saying it's over but at
the end of the day you still want to
have your respect that you had when you
was in the game see right now i got
friends they work they do all kind of
stuff but guess what though i still love
them i don't care what they do and
everything because guess what we still
here we still living and i love them you
know and i hope they feel the same way
about me you know what i'm saying and i
don't feel like that i'm better than
them because about what things that i do
and everything i feel guess what we're
still on equal scale you see them saying
but my career
just lasted because my job description
remains the same
you know
and that's for real
that's why i love kenny he's the
straightest shooter there is kenny it
will give you the brutal truth he is not
a pretty little liar even though he's
very handsome
but i appreciate that
yeah kenny's a very reasonable man yes
he is and that's why i stayed with him
and loved him because he always took
care of business i didn't have to do
nothing but go get
money
everything was laid out he used to buy
me buy my clothes you know i can go
shopping too but you know just he might
see something he like and might want to
see me in it and it'll be laid across
the bed you know
um
kenny takes care of business like bills
are gonna be paid three and four months
in advance like you getting a lot of
money your bills gonna be paid a year in
advance you know kenny don't like to not
no bills to catch up on us like he pays
bills
some people do not like to pay bills
mckinney always was a bill payer always
kept no are our records cool if we had
warrants or anybody if a new [ __ ] even
came in our family and was getting money
he i didn't see him straighten up a
whole [ __ ] whole life you know what i'm
saying she has so many warrants from the
last she had he didn't just let never
took her to court and she was just cased
up and kenny changed her whole life got
her license
you know you know you know who taught me
the how to handle my business and
everything
was gangsta brown i watched gang i watch
brown take care of business i watch
gangster i watch gangster get do his
credit and everything i and i follow i
follow this lead i remember when we got
in the game and i mean when i got in the
game and everything [ __ ] i mean we had
no idea me gangsta my other partners and
we didn't even have no identification
and so gangsta was like where y'all come
oh we just came from dmv this back in
1980 you know what i'm saying 80 81 who
just came from dmv we riding cadillacs
and uh limousines and everything ain't
nobody got no damn driving like no
identification level you know what i'm
saying and i watch i watch brown
transition to do everything so by me
being the youngster about them you know
i'm saying so i learned you see i'm
saying
yeah yeah yeah his student and i just
kept pushing forward though you know
what i'm saying that's just like i come
from the gangster brown field muslim
family you know but i'm still here but
i'm i'm against the best student that
gangsta brown never ever [ __ ] had
he'll tell you that you know what i'm
saying but at the same time i remember
phil motorola's one time back it was at
the hollywood vine told me me an
international blue and charlie clap yeah
y'all pimps but i'll pimp circles around
you youngsters i'm a [ __ ] mac
phil mo say he been having hoes before
when they had horses and carriages out
and i believe old man
got to pay homage you got to pay homage
and that's what be wrong with these
youngsters we need to make ism great
again i i i i had a few a few i've had a
bunch of [ __ ] had a bunch of my
folks calling me be like is martina
still in the game i said [ __ ] i call her
her just [ __ ] that [ __ ] to tell you
what she if she is still going what she
would do and everything i said but
when they be talking about retirement
and all that kind of stuff so
[ __ ] be talking about they
retired this and everything okay well
[ __ ] if a [ __ ] come off of me a hundred
thousand dollars do i supposed to take
it or supposed to be like oh no i
retired i you know said i don't accept
that no more come on man please that's
the same way just like what uh uh uh uh
uh uh uh uh ex lady at leisure you see
i'm saying i'm oh she oh but actually if
a [ __ ] came offered her
ten thousand hundred thousand i said
what's she taking see what you do they
got the opportunity to ask you now sock
it to a [ __ ] okay
okay
okay check this out i don't care how old
i get i'm never [ __ ] for free
i never quote me on that
quote me on that even if you give me a
stipend every month and come [ __ ] me
four times a month check this out
sugardaddy.com still be popping for me
you know what i'm saying i'm a sugar
baby and i'm 55 years old yeah and today
my birthday i just turned 61 years old
you know what i'm saying god bless you
thank you you know i appreciate that
many more yeah yeah yeah we're on our
way to the to the party the players bar
everybody was invited you know said
that's just like martin and people be
like is martinez uh still with y'all
mark martinez been with me about how
long about 25 26 years or something like
that yeah yeah martina ain't gave me no
money the last time she gave about 25 26
years we ain't [ __ ] me i'll do nothing
none of that we just cool you see what
i'm saying and that's it that's all you
know guess what she got my back i got
her back i appreciate what she didn't
done for me you see i'm saying she i
mean you know she went out there and
made sure i was straight made sure my
bills were straight made sure she was
straight my nephew's in there she'd been
there you know when i had tragedies in
the family and all that you know and
that'll go along i'm not gonna uh you
have been there for me yeah well my
tragedy with my brother rico died i'm
not gonna just uh disclose any other
female that i have had and everything
because they was there too you know
and we ought to have like i said we all
didn't have our ups and downs but you
know what i'm saying uh uh uh uh um i
appreciate the things that the females
have done for me and like i say like i
told you before mark it was anything
that i could do for a female that i had
that i have ever had and they need
something i got it you could get it mark
you see what i'm saying i mean okay i
can't take it with me you know what i'm
saying that's just like with me sharing
the game with the youngsters and
everything i shared a game with them
because i shared right you see what i'm
saying so [ __ ] you won't be in
trouble you know what i'm saying and
everything but if you don't want to
listen that's on you not me you can't
say that okay red he uh hollywood no
i'll tell you i'm hollywood but i'm
really hollyhood though you know what
i'm saying because that's where i come
from right you know yeah believe that
you know so if if a female wanted to
come fool with me guess what if you
don't like what come out of my mouth and
you don't want it right then this [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] with me because i'm not going
to tell you no lie right you know what
i'm going to keep it 100 which you know
what i'm saying i'm old but guess what i
still got it though but you find like
wine like when wine gets better with
time oh yeah like me
that's why i'm a happy hooker and that's
why i don't have wrinkles that's what
you're happy i'm a happy cooker you know
and i just love to love i love this ism
and i'm trying to leave breadcrumbs for
these young girls to follow to not make
the mistakes that i made i want them to
get all the money and i'm proud of them
having all these avenues to get the
money that they getting man if i had 20
if i had 20 years backwards
man i'll be doing everything i would
never get no sleep
yeah i mean
i would never get no sleep this is just
so many ways to get money and i just
love to see him get it you know you want
me to tell you let me tell you the key
to the game though for real for real
and i hope everybody listen and pay
attention when they see this interview
the key to the game
is health is your wealth it's about
living they they go they
when they see when the people see this
interview we're going to have critics
they're going to have to you know they
had a thumbs up the thumbs down but
remember one thing at 61
i'm 61 today martina 55 i'm 55. i'm
never she she's 55 and everything but
guess what though remember one thing
they have to do this you simply said
they have to get here to be able to talk
about what they have done and still look
like this i was just in the gym not too
long ago i left 405 on the bench for my
sons and then i'm totally i when y'all
turn 60 years old make sure you be able
to pick up the same four wheels that i
did that 405 on the bench you see what
i'm saying yes i'm not trying to i don't
be trying to hear that [ __ ] you know you
know when you get to different levels
it's new devils and a wise man matter of
fact it was magic don juan that told me
accept the love ignore the hate and i've
been using that mantra and it's been
helping me i don't even look at bad
comments you know what i mean i ignore
the i accept the love and i ignore the
hate and that's what bishop don juan
told me
and uh yeah i take that to my grave hey
that's just like what you mark you
didn't interview that i i i just seen on
the comment mark want to be a pip and
everything why
yeah i know i know i know you not know
pimp mark and you ain't trying to be one
i know that you just enjoy you know
people's lifestyle and interview and you
just put it out there you see what i'm
saying see people really don't know that
you know what i'm saying that you don't
even have to do this you see them saying
you got all your own [ __ ] and everything
you know what i'm saying and i know that
you're a good dude because if you
wouldn't i wouldn't be sitting right
here you know what i'm saying but you do
enjoy this journalism
i love it
all the characters that are hanging out
today
mark is like one of the 90210 white boys
on the beach you know because that's how
you dress up every time you got
because he's getting so much knowledge
and education and you're sitting here
like learning with these people like
with the yeah they're like like like
yeah i'm getting education from the best
you're getting it from the horse's mouth
bishop sharp all these yeah that's the
best
yeah and see that's just like you know
saying more like i say you know back you
know back to the game everything you
know martine i just want to tell you on
camera i appreciate you appreciate
everything that you have done for me and
everything you know i'm saying that you
know we're gonna be friends to the end
and everything you know what i'm saying
and uh
you know you got the job done you know
saying i'll give you two thumbs up i
appreciate you though let's get this
money done let's get this money we need
a movie you know what i said it's gonna
be better than i can tonight well well
that's like mike f my friend mike said
mike already told me can you read your
life was interesting he said i'm going
to play your part whenever they get
their writing and everything i got a few
people that's writing a few things but i
really don't talk about no nothing you
know me i move better on action than
words you see what i'm saying i don't
like want to talk about this and talk
about that because i have had friends to
go talk about this who playing this and
who doing it and nothing never come out
of it i'm saying so
you know if the lord will and if it's
meant for me to have i have it if not
then hey i appreciate you know what i'm
saying my fans the people that
love me the people that uh uh uh
that's been behind me you know i'm
saying even the haters you know what i'm
saying because i know it'll be a few
haters they'll be calling you know my on
my instagram on my ig my facebook but
what i never understood why the haters
why do
if people don't like what you say or
what you do why do you even get on there
why don't you just delete your own self
see i never understood it delete your
own you know what i want you to delete
your own self you know invisible yeah
and they're trailers and that's their
job they're haters you don't have to
make no comment or no nothing keep the
comment to yourself and just delete
yourself off my page that's all you got
to do and that's where i'm not bothering
you i'm not asking you for nothing i
don't even know you you know that's when
it goes back to accept the love ignore
the haters but you know what i'm trying
to do mark i want to be on power i wish
50 cent cd so i could be mary jane uh
live big sister so we can kill lorenzo
you know what i mean
put me in the sequence get me in
somewhere you know what i mean i got
this big personality and i just want to
show the world you know and i just want
to share my life with all the ladies
that have been through everything i'm
going through but they can't say it
you know i'm speaking for a lot of women
out there in the world yeah there's a
lot of females they love you martin and
i love them back i love all y'all back
hustle mom love y'all man
and um i'm just leaving breadcrumbs and
just letting you guys see all the
content all my life i just want you guys
to make my life a movie so you guys can
be captivated and and that would make my
day if i die tomorrow and just letting
my life and you know showing my life
story to people
i'd be happy
i'll notice i'll i'll be happy i'll be
with the ancestors happy you know one
thing marty i would ask you
if i could turn back the hands of time
would i do it again what i said and
watch it after though you goddamn right
one bow tie for the record
all right martina and kenny thank you so
much for coming back okay well mark
they've been waiting they've been
waiting to see see this what's going on
i hope we answered your questions
properly and everything you know what
you guys want to know
but you know hey we said i love it
and appreciate you guys
and we love this ism
ism is a culture and it's a vernacular
and we love it awesome okay you got us
thank you
you